government can come along and with all
the best intentions hi I'm Zack Weiss
Muller for a reason TV I'm here with
Gary Taubes science writer and author of
multiple books including good calories
bad calories the diet delusion and most
recently why we get fat and what to do
about it
Gary thanks for joining us thanks for
having me your science writer and a lot
of what's gotten you attention is you're
writing about nutrition what first got
you interested in the topic well I had
done a couple of books on controversial
science what good scientists refer to as
pathological science which are this
science of things that aren't so after
the second book which was about this
fiasco called cold fusion that took
place in the late 1980s some of my
friends in the physics community said
well if you think the science and cold
fusion was bad you should look at some
of this stuff in public health and
everything I had learned about how to do
good science in my 10 years previously
as a science writer turned out you
didn't actually have to do an
observational epidemiology it's your
belief that carbohydrate intensive diets
are actually harmful and that we should
be eating animal fat butter salt all
that stuff in the 1960s when the field
of nutrition was kind of merging
fully-blown as a subject of serious
study in the u.s. it latched on to two
ideas one is that dietary fat is the
cause of heart disease and so we should
eat low-fat diets and if you can eat
low-fat diet to a place of fat with
carbohydrates and the other is this idea
that obesity is all about just energy
balance calories in versus calories out
and it makes it gluttony and sloth and
effective in the biblical terms these
two ideas dietary fat causes heart
disease obesity is just a disorder
reading too much and nothing else became
sort of the foundation of everything
that happened since the 60s as those
hypotheses got tested on evidence never
came around to support it but one of the
things that happened is as a nutrition
public health the sort of establishment
grew
from the 1960s onward the existence of
these hypotheses was considered reason
enough to believe they were true you
mentioned that the standards in
epidemiology seem to be unusually loose
why is this why is there so much
pseudoscience and nutrition
the first major obesity textbook to be
written in the US and the 20th century
was published in 1940 by a Hungarian
emigres at Northwestern University out
of about 500 references some 200-plus
were from the german language literature
and then the war comes in the next
obesity book written is in 1948 it's a
clinical guide by - Mayo Clinic
physicians they have five hundred some
references in twelve are from the German
language literature and so we just not
only did we put behind sort of ignore
everything that had been learned by
these researchers about the potential
cause of obesity
we lost the culture of science that
allowed them to learn those things so
it's as though not only did we invent
nutrition metabolism obesity research
from scratch in the 1950s the people
doing it kind of invented what they
thought was science in the 1950s when
you make these claims you obviously
ruffle a lot of feathers in their
scientific establishment you've faced
your fair number of critiques some of
them in Reason magazine you went back
and forth with a writer and we'll link
that in our video one of the popular
contentions as you mentioned is a
calories in calories out hypothesis and
it it seems to make sense on the surface
just consume less calories than you
expend and you'll lose fat briefly
describe why that that's mistaken and
how that notion came to be german
diabetes specialist back in 1903 1905
suggested that obesity was caused merely
by taking in more calories and expended
it's like we're going to imply this
apply this new science of thermodynamics
to this age-old or you know serious
problem of obesity and it was naive then
you know I mean we're biological
organisms we're not physical organism if
we wanted to ask the question why
elephants have more fat on them
than cheetahs we would never apply
thermodynamics to any of these issues
it's only in obesity that suddenly it
becomes about energy rather about the
hormonal regulation of the fat tissue
the government and other I guess
informational institutions are the
subject of your critique also describe
how knowledge kind of gets stuck almost
in 1950s a University of Minnesota
nutritionist named Ann soaky's comes up
with this idea that dietary fat causes
heart disease particularly animal fats
and the American Heart Association gets
behind it when there's effectively no
experimental data whatsoever to confirm
that it's true the congressional
committee run by George McGovern that
had been founded in the late 1960s to
deal with hunger and America decides
they're gonna get on board also they put
together a report called the dietary
goals for the United States and it just
seems reasonable that one of the things
they should tell us all to do is eat
less fat more carbohydrate so they do
and then the USDA says look at what this
great thing that that McGovern's
Committee is trying to do so the USDA
gets on board and it just steamed most
once it gets rolling in one direction
there's not much of an incentive - not
much of an incentive to stop because the
studies never came around but it's very
hard for these government organizations
very hard for the health organizations
like the American Heart Association to
acknowledge making an error so once
you've started giving advice how do you
pull back and say we were wrong yeah how
do you and I have no idea I mean I used
to joke about the American Heart
Association putting out a press release
apologizing saying look we've sorry that
for the last 50 years we've been giving
the wrong advice and maybe we killed
some of you were killed some of your
relatives or you know your loved ones
and that's you know too bad but now we
got the advice right and now you can
trust us part of it is they should be
being held accountable by science
writers journalists well there's a lot
of ways that the science and health
writers don't live up to their
obligations as a journalist one is more
in any other field there seems to be
this belief that what we should be doing
is faithfully sort of translating the
science and the medical pronouncements
from the government and the research is
directly to the public
I had a Washington Post nutrition writer
tell me that she thought her job was to
faithfully represent what the USDA said
about diet to the rest of the American
public and I'm thinking imagine any
other reporter even a sports reporter
who believed that his or her job was to
faithfully represent what the coach of
their local team was telling rather than
asking is this good advice or not and
what evidence is there to support it
what would you have to see to say you
know what low-fat high-carb advocates
are right what would convince you that
that hypothesis is the right one and
that's an interesting question because
that hypothesis has been tested and I'd
argue it fails effectively every test
and we spent roughly a half million
dollars on the Women's Health Initiative
they took 49 thousand women randomized
them so 20,000 got low saturated fat
relatively high carbohydrate diet near
the 29,000 ate as usual and that low fat
low carbohydrate diet had no benefits
whatsoever ideally what you would do is
do the same kind of study and compare
this low fat low carb or high
carbohydrate modestly calorie restricted
diet to the high-fat low-carbohydrate
diet unrestricted in calories and do it
for 10 years and a lot of people and
then if that low fat low calorie high
carb diet did better then that would be
pretty conclusive evidence for reasons I
don't quite understand the low carb diet
whether it's Atkins or paleo or primal
has become somewhat popular within
libertarian circles do you have any idea
what that's about it could be as simple
as several libertarians influential
libertarians finding it works for them I
think libertarians probably like the
idea that government
agencies and federal agencies can just
be dead wrong about issues so you know I
find that I'm I have fans in the
economics community because they love
the idea that there's a science out
there that might be worse and
macroeconomics the actually a lot of
political economists seem to be
fascinated by my work because of these
implications that a there could be these
simple ideas out there that have been
lying there and have never been embraced
and are right and be that you know
influential they the government can come
along and and with all the best
intentions causing enormous problems
you